Robert with crowdsource studios and the
films that you plan to make these are
all low budget films initially yeah
definitely and that's I think that's a
bad thing I used to be when you thought
low-budget you thought crude and cheap
and not crude you know what I mean just
amateur so yeah definitely low budget
but I think that's I don't think that's
a bad thing I mean I think of like I
said blue ruin or blood simple if it was
made today or just simple stories told
well and there you know it's from a
financial standpoint too i mean the the
the highest grossing film in terms of
return on investment is paranormal
activity that was an eleven thousand
dollar movie that's returned two hundred
million dollars so you don't need to
spend a lot of money to set to tell a
simple story in addition to which i just
i saw Jurassic world recently and the
guy who directed Jurassic world which is
150 million dollar studio tentpole
juggernaut movie directed one feature
before it was safety not guaranteed
750,000 dollar movie right that was his
he went from the 750 thousand dollar
movie to a hundred and fifty million
dollar movie so yeah you can totally
prove yourself in a little movie
absolutely yeah
you